ils sont juges substitut fier greffier
3000 d'entre eux ont signé une tribune
dans le quotidien le monde pour évoquer
la dégradation de leurs conditions de
travail et le manque de moyens de la
justice sont déplorés chez entre autres
des audiences surchargé elle des arrêts
maladie en cascade des audiences classer
sans suite ou encore l'obligation de
traiter des affaires de divorce en 15
minutes sans pouvoir donner la parole
aux parties aujourd'hui nous témoignons
car nous ne voulons plus d'une justice
qui n'écoutent pas qui résonnent
uniquement en chiffres qui chronomètre
tout et comptabilise tous nous
magistrats faisons le même constat que
les justiciables nous comprenons que les
personnes aient plus confiance
aujourd'hui en la justice que nous
rendons car nous sommes finalement
confronté à un dilemme intenable jugé
vite mais mal ou jugés bien mais dans
des délais inacceptables
ce constat inquiétant déjà ancien et
probablement devenu insupportable à
leurs yeux à la suite d'une tragédie le
suicide d'une jeune magistrate charlotte
29 ans a mis fin à ses jours en août
dernier après deux années éprouvantes a
passé de tribunal en tribunal pour
pallier les sous-effectifs de
juridiction en souffrance du nord et du
pas de calais à ses conditions de
travail difficiles s'ajoutaient des
injonctions d'aller toujours plus vite
et de faire du chiffre mais charlotte
refusé de faire primer la quantité sur
la qualité elle refusait de travailler
de façon dégradé à plusieurs reprises au
cours de l'année qui a précédé son décès
charlotte alerter ses collègues sur la
souffrance que lui causer son travail
comme beaucoup elle a travaillé durant
presque tous ses week-ends et ses
vacances mais cela n'a pas suffi se sont
ensuivies un arrêt de travail une
première tentative de suicide nous
souhaitons affirmer que charlotte n'est
pas un cas isolé une colère et un
ras-le-bol qui sont parvenues jusqu'aux
garde des sceaux eric dupond-moretti
devrait d'ailleurs dans les prochains
jours recevoir une délégation de
signataires de la tribune le directeur
des services judiciaires du ministère de
la justice a pour sa part déjà reconnu
qu'il fallait augmenter les effectifs
pour répondre aux tensions présentes
dans le monde judiciaire
il faut augmenter le nombre de
magistrats et de greffiers
650 magistrats et 850 greffiers
supplémentaires ont été affectés durant
le quinquennat à des oufs dans des
proportions inégalées dans le passé cet
appel intervient alors que les états
généraux de la justice sont ouverts
depuis fin octobre initié par le
président de la république le rendez
vous doit se pencher sur plusieurs
dossiers brûlants comme l'inflation
judiciaire ou encore la suppression de
la cour de justice de la république
la cour de justice de la république qui
a est le seul organe habilité à juger
les membres du gouvernement pour des
infractions commises dans le cadre de
leur mandat